Foxy's contributor Sarah Carter she was
reporting from East Palestine earlier
this week and Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett uh Sarah let's talk to you
uh tell us specifically what did you see
and what are you hearing today as the
follow-up I can't believe it's been two
weeks and they're out there saying well
just trust the government we'll be fine
I mean that is absurd
yeah it is absurd Jason look I met
wonderful families uh residents of East
Palestine Ohio that couldn't even I
couldn't even imagine being in their
shoes I went out there I saw homes that
were right at Ground Zero met this
wonderful lady Shelby who was actually
on Sean's show this week she took me to
her home literally the train carts were
in her backyard her son was there with
us he's 12 years old she was saying to
me how can I even trust this soil nobody
has come to my home to do testing nobody
has come to my home to speak to me
nobody from the railroad from the
government now that was the same night
that they were having a meeting she said
now we're supposed to trust the
government we're supposed to trust the
fact that they're going to come here and
do for us what we needed done two weeks
ago and I get that because I walked out
to the streams with other residents and
another residents named Bill who is a
water was from a well in his backyard
and actually the stream that was running
through East Palestine that he took me
to off of 170 was filled listen to this
Jason with dead fish there were fish
dead everywhere the and it was recent it
wasn't like fish that had been there two
weeks ago you could tell that these fish
were recently they had recently died and
moved Downstream frogs other animals
that were in the Stream other uh Little
Little Critters that lived in the Stream
like crawfish and snails all dead along
the stream and Bill said to me do you
think I really want to take a shower in
my well water with this do you think I
would allow my grandchildren or my
children to bathe in this and we're
supposed to trust the government when
they have blatantly lied to us and now
we know Pete butterjudge didn't show up
either so I think there's a huge concern
across the board Jason that they are not
being told the truth and and bigger
question is they're showing up now but
what about the effects of that chemical
plume right when it went off under that
controlled burn and that's something I
mean are they going to have medical
doctors testing everyone that's another
issue
yeah according to the Associated Press
one of the articles I read Greg the Ohio
Department of Natural Resources is
estimating there were 3 500 dead fish in
in the streams nearby five of the wells
they they tested said that they were
just fine but you've got to believe that
if the animals are dying do you really
want to be there breathing that air
drinking that water and being in close
proximity with a government that's going
to show up weeks after this and not
there in the first 48 hours they may
have had a couple people there but the
Department of Transportation is supposed
to be there and then government makes
the decision hey let's burn this stuff
you know let's throw it up in the air
that'll be good that'll make it safer
and we're supposed to trust the
government come on
hmm you'd have to be a lunatic to trust
the U.S government especially in the
Biden Administration as you point out
this is a horrible health environmental
and transportation disaster and yet Pete
butterjudge the Secretary of
Transportation is nowhere to be seen in
steady dismisses it say no you know this
happens all the time and besides it
Donald Trump's fault this is a guy who
should be fired not just for ranking
competence but a disgraceful level of
indifference but this kind of stupidity
is what you get when you pick somebody
who is not qualified and has no
experience and where is Joe Biden in all
of this I mean he at least traveled to
the state of Ohio and pretend that you
care and instead he outright rejected
the pleas for disaster relief on the
grounds that oh well FEMA only provides
relief for natural disasters that's not
what the law says the law that created
FEMA says both natural disaster and
man-made disasters and of course you've
got the EP on EPA on the ground saying
oh everything is fine and dandy you can
drink your water you can breathe the air
not just the fish that have died
thousands of them but livestock and pets
are sick and if people are sicken I mean
they're describing debilitating
headaches painful rashes breathing
problems a wide variety of concerns and
you had six toxic chemicals that were
blown up into the air in the environment
and cars and Lawns and and rooftops are
covered in soot and we're supposed to
trust the government that everything is
just fine
don't trust this government
well you can all you have to do is ask
the people of Flint Michigan if they
should trust the government with all the
water and all the problems they went to
they had a water main break last week
and guess what they're still being told
to boil their water before they bathe in
it and before they drink it and uh what
the how this Administration is dealing
with this man-made environmental
disaster is just horrific Sarah Greg
thank you for joining us on Hannity
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else